Well the biggest success in technology that this communities achieved.
Is not so much that we've got wonderful new brilliant. Energy systems going or anything like that.
We've got a few demonstration projects to prove it's possible.
We've got a big harder electrics going we've got my flying folks transport.
The things you can actually poke a stick at the site. This is radical. Appropriate soft soft technology.
But if you look at statistics of the whole community is lost all of the property what.
The any why are we really winning. As far as the planet's concerned is the fact that we're not using nearly as much.
We've got both a lot less of a sink. And we found that it doesn't really matter all that much. It's enough.
And it's you know decisions. That. Someone said to me that you. Well it was always a bit of a nifty project.
There was never an enormous push behind that project. Was buying more land there's always been incredible push for.
Scenic route so that's because more growing land but that's not totally true. It's more the feeling of.
Wishing to consolidate. People wishing for security and. I mean in this whole valley.
Was a very important political and ideological strength behind this community.
It meant that as a community we had last night. We had to have a conflict. Direct night as with different ideas.
Other communities have a great big legal fight siva pesticides bryan that blows up the fences
and things like that because we are in the whole valley we don't have that.
On a couple of occasions fawaz have come out of the ridge line from the night. And with.
I'm taking him to court and a couple of occasions he's come along dell logs. Of the border.
It would made a big fuss about it. So that's about the any direction with head would be on very solid grounds.
Was what it was on humans wonderful for tolerance. Niman is a wonderfully tolerant place. It's one place like even.
One outside the black spots of newton. Which is the runback cafe and the freemasons hotel.
The free license hotel is my favorite hotel anywhere. It's usually full of. Appalling music.
Horrible looking people and people like using drugs and drinking to excess. But never in my whole.
Twenty years of going. Frequenting that place of i've been assaulted.
Of drunk with totally obnoxious looking back east. With undercover police.
With some of the most suspicious looking g.b.'s people that you did see and yet there was never a threat to person.
This is a wonderful cosmopolitan thing in that different cultures are respected.
And you feel that you could just about walk down the street and i could act on as someone who did.
And no one would take the slightest notice. And yet. It's also a place where you know everybody. And i know you.
And if you desperate someone might even lend you five dollars. On dia i could go on. Yes.
The funniest newman story i know. I guess this doesn't. I'm sure this is likely i can decide. Was that.
One of the audio logical. Latest during a christmas festival.
Who's very keen on place love and nonviolence and his child conceived. Equerries festival is called softly.
Tended to be the most beautiful flower child. He actually assaulted.
One of the still roula got dragged into court for it and the anything you could cite after being convicted was.
I should have had the same fellow unfortunately got must've irritated some baki equally.
And i promptly shot him in the new caps and left the body in the in the corrie up the top of the hill.
So i sort of had total sympathy. I mean. Oh it's a most irritating man.
This was the environment that that man shed which is possibly forgotten. Sometimes moonlight nights.
You just come crashing out of the forest obviously having walked five kilometers through that totally on one track bush.
In the middle of the knot and he'd have a wildfire and he saw as lucky. He was like an animal out of the forest and.
I could relate to that because part of the whole point this is a communal communality.
Of all the animals that live in the forest.
I love the fact that all these animals just walk in
and out of my house as if it's part of the track which was a wise thing. I just happen to build my house.
At the joining of three tracks. And the animals treat it still is.
Just exactly what it was a meeting of those three tracks. Very much so. Yes yes yes.
It was since i started taking my friends. I was very worried about.
What consciousness is what we who we want to do all for less fundamental spiritual questions.
And one of the things i came to us that there wasn't any reason. They just used. And all animals that i.
It sounds semantically tautological but that still the feel about these animals that walk around the forest.
And i'm more no less than i am. So being able to just go by in place and have to go on as and the keys and.
All these amazing creatures just come and look at me when i'm sitting there watching television.
To me is that an amazing event with. Ones. You know. I don't take it that.
I don't think there's anything wrong with squashing not flaws.
Fact i find it quite amusing you squash them then you want to listen to them. That part of the cycle.
So i'm not a buddhist in that sense of no form last but really just fuse off head.
Except that i don't believe in any of them and. None of it makes sense.
But i'm quite prepared to leave it not making sense. Strong yes.
Of course if one doesn't mention the difference most people tend to be buddhist in the sense of. Doing old life.
Thinking that that the mountains the trees everything has spirit. Which it does.
Well the most beautiful spiritual times he was walking around the valley bottom then lot.
You feel like you've come back to a probably evil. World beyond before time and. It's the middle of the dice.
And you wearing sunglasses. That's the closest i can express what it's like to walk around this valley bahman lot.
It's so quiet. You can hear a cough it. Five kilometers away. Usually you can even tell which carries. Now. That's.
It's important but when you live in somewhere like sydney where you might hear a siren. Three straight so white.
And that's about it. So yes. This valley is acoustically one unit and. You smell things here.
It's got wonderful smell things got beautiful sounds like going mentions it not time walking around here you can you
all of the birds. The. Different sorts of owls not just the.
You can hear things going on in the wallabies hopping around. It's like it's a whole world happening.
It's just the there are people dominating. We just one more not animal walking around in.
Music was almost the driving force in this culture. This aquarian culture.
We had the protest movement we had bob dylan joan brought us all of those people. And i really created the dream.
I mentioned before we broke celtic in fusion rock. But it's also the ballad. You get people like john barr to sing.
The scene. About. Like the circle song as one of the classic. It's about the circle of life and. One of the key lines.
About the boy. He will change the car will strew the town.
And then the next person and his dreams of lost that granger coming through. I see a lot of the people around me.
Feeling a little bit sort of jaded about the tunnel experience. And it's sometimes.
Hills a bit like a a hole and i camp. Or some much like a bitch. Place where people go to a top. And die.
But i think partly it's because the dreams that come true. That's lost. And it's all sort of worn off a bit.
Because sometimes it's not the reality of what's happened but the why the. People feel about it.
Which affects the why they talk about it. So i feel it was inspirational. Creating a new vision. Thing which is being.
What the led zeppelin song. Stairway to heaven. That was one of the humans. Of our movement and.
Everyone can play that song on the guitar. It's just one of the sort of. Rites of passage in this community. And the.
The forest will echo with laughter. Is one of the westernizing lines in the middle of that song.
And it's funny because it brings together the two elements of this culture which i've always found contradictory.
Ones to the forest echoing the laughter the solids. On the other hand. The incredible.
Noise with which most people play music around here.
Right from beginning bobbie cries
and scalpels down there which was the nearest point is electricity where you could plug in a thousand
and one amplifier. Was shaking and shocking the whole valley with really quite miserable doors top. Rock and roll and.
All the concerts round here. I couldn't really like his cultural and learn to wear earplugs. And now.
Before i go to do any concert round here i pluck up my ears with with toilet paper.
And you simply have to run a few reasons i think that i've got still my hearing.
With many people around here are quite different. It's one of the.
Most theories about the communication between people. Is extremely simple.
People don't communicate because half the people are too stunned.
To talk out here at least the other half to death here and. You know.
I think that the communications the lifeblood of any community and we're not doing enough to have one scene.
Well that's what twenty five. We've collected. Yes. The. The burden of being seen as a visionary santa is wonderful.
For example my immediate neighborhood. Is now totally repopulated.
On the only person who's there in the original hamlet. All the people have come adjournments except for one tiny.
Was not all that christian from. Up in queensland. But. All of the others the germans.
Germans know more about nimbin than astride and stu. It's considered a mecca for anti-authoritarian forces.
With the call themselves. Jockeys around it is to well. It doesn't really matter.
The point is the anti the state and the bin i have inspected i have a defected i was really think.
In germany by an excessively efficient public service. They come here to a skype it is the opposite point of the globe.
As the opposite in culturally. And for that reason we've got all these wonderful immigrant germans.
Who are skilled ambitious.
Old enough and have the wherewithal to be constructive and mild and i've always been totally rebuilt.
You know wonderful why by the. Ingress of all these wonderful germans.
So it's attracted a lot of negative attention from government bureaucracies. For example if i. When i get.
Regularly stopped. Because i drive an old car. I was looking for lawson's and.
The fact that the law says the wrong gender doesn't seem to both of them.
What bothers them is this is the would tolerable foals.
Like promptly get out and start searching the cuff marihuana the image of the place. Is got a lot of attention.
Unwanted. But police and. Drug traffickers in general. It was beautifully ambiguous.
But yes it's been also wonderful drawcard. But we've got an unbelievable string of tele did.
Wonderful people come to this property. Most of whom with used polling and consumed and spat out.
My biggest guilt about this community has helped pull the we've seen many of the very talented. Adil it.
Adia logically. Motivated people. Because what's happened to this community is built of the. The cream and the dregs.
The bus come together where i'm selective and often i'm not quite sure. Sometimes. Which category to put people in.
It's not that i'm being judgmental. It's just simply.
The fact that people come here sometimes for their own purposes and sometimes the community purposes.
Just occasionally enlightened self interest. Like some sort of but masters. I can't write my name is sally spain and.
I came to newman. In one hundred seventy six like nine hundred seventy six and. I've lived here. On and off since then.
On and off because some of the time i go over the border. The aborigines used to call this country.
The country of the men. And ice into this armies. On mount warning. And the terrain here.
Is rougher than where i grew up which is just over the border in south east queensland. Which kath walker once told me.
Was with stradbroke on and then. And mt tamborine the country. Of the women.
And i find that the values that are expressed in both of these places one on each side of the border.
Are part and parcel of the same thing. I don't know how many people would agree with me.
Because a lot of the people who came to newman. And some of them were the very best of our generation.
Came from sydney and. In those days we had. Because of the hard work of our parents' generation.
A lot of freedom to discuss and talk about the ideas. And out of the universities and the colleges and the workplaces.
They came a feeling that it would be good in in view of some of the crises that seem to be be setting the world.
To set up an ideal society. And young and naive as we were. I think we expected to walk out of the country and.
Set one up. Just like that. Of course twenty years later. When people talk about it. That's fine. Yes. It's heartening.
You sure.
Of course twenty years later when people talk about it i see the vision
and i also see some of the disappointments as well as some of the things that have been achieved.
I think in our generation.
And the generations later on haven't had such total freedom because of the economic times that came upon us.
We had an opportunity to express some of the things that we believed in which was a whole lifestyle with with trust
and friendship with people and. Some connection to the earth again and. A rural community. Fresh air and.
Freedom to bring about children.
Perhaps in a way outside of the city areas and so on and i think in a lot of cases some of this has been achieved.
In other cases it hasn't. Because people have got side tracked.
Drugs were a problem with adj interaction and they were other issues too.
But newman and you know why has been a learning center. Many more people than are actually here now. Have passed by.
And some of them have learnt difficult lessons here because it wasn't easy to come from.
At least a samia been lifestyle. And suddenly plant oneself in a rural area.
But some of the people who have come here have found friendship. I think.
From some of them found disappointment also because of course the vision.
Couldn't always be immediately realized or even ever realized perhaps.
But it doesn't mean that a lot of the people you haven't held on to the principles that i espoused when i
when i dropped out as that was what was called in the. Days. That's what i think of right now you.
Yeah i think probably some partly that's contributed to by the terrain i mean in a sense.
We're doing both things because we live in queensland.
And my husband works and we've got our children now at school are taught them in the early years. But.
To a degree we've got we've got rough terrain and.
To walk across to our neighbors there is something that you can't really do.
Because you've got to sort of hack your way through or go. Right round via a long way. And i think.
Just dealing with planting which is and building houses and.
Looking after children it might mean that people don't associate.
But otherwise i think they do when i was here more full time.
And the little school was down there the children was at the kindergarten and.
I would go down to be part of the committee of the school and i think through group endeavors.
People get a lot of their social life where i might hop skip across to a neighbor because of the actual nature of the
terrain. I don't know that answer your questions. Was sure i think that's right.
And that's what we were talking about before i think if you have a community where it's group life.
Then you make some sacrifices to be part of the group.
And sometimes that's that's individual and such individual ready and sometimes.
That means that you have to bow to group pressures and. Sometimes the group is wrong. So there's always that danger.
I mean sometimes it's correct you get some energy from people being different and you're free to be different.
Amongst them. And to express what you feel you should express. But on the other hand.
There is that there is too only by the group. And i think that can happen too. And that's something that.
That would bother me i think you know why because i tend to like to people on an individual level.
So i found beautiful friends here. But. But i avoid the tribal meetings because it bothers me that some decision.
Can be made and perhaps that's an unjust decision. Not always but it can mean.
It's a reflection of what it does mean and it's. I mean it's just you know i think there are things there are.
There are great lessons that can be learnt from what's happened here. But there's also with every step forward.
Sometimes i think there's a step backwards i mean people here are more conscious of a healthy lifestyle. And night.
They are more conscious of having organic food. But because they landed in a run for us sometimes.
Hygiene and sanitation. Was slack whereas if you. If you went up to the causeway the councils had more control.
In the hinterland their.
Sanitation was all right
but people might not realize so much about that there were alternative ways of dealing with health problems
and things like that. It was. It was always very dualistic. That's what i found.
I mean if i breastfed the children here. Publicly to a light. That was never a problem. If i did it up there.
You know over the border. That was more conspicuous. But if i fed the children sweets down here.
Which i think is perfectly correct. Then that might be a cause of some neighborly interference.
If i fed them sweets out there. That was not a problem. It was like that always i was had that experience.
If i birth the children at home.
Up there which i did because our house wasn't finished and my mother was up there she was a midwife.
Then that wasn't a problem. Here people said that home birth is fine. And in those days i had.
I had no feeling of going near a hospital i had three healthy children. But.
But if i if i was home birthing out there people would. Would cite.
Good heavens how and got it off you saw i always had this experience of living between.
But not so much now i think that some of the ideas that were that were current and that were good.
The ideas that came here. Have spread widely so that when i say to my cousins. Look you don't have to come up here.
To see you know if you've been. Being true to your traditions these training traditions of.
Of looking after your children and having. Basic morality. And giving them. You know healthy lifestyle and.
Keeping them in touch with nature. Then that women are different to them i mean it's not so different now.
So much as you know. Because i don't know i draw a lot of strength from beautiful people who are here. You know.
That have come i mean i've met some extraordinary songs here. Who came.
You know with the most beautiful ideas and managed to manifest them but.
But also i mean we had people who were traveling through who were who were. You know out of it.
Who had had had too many drugs who were difficult to deal with we've had both very extreme.
And i've been more free to express themselves here and i would have in other places. But i don't draw.
So much from the group life as a whole that i did
when the children were going to the kindergarten so it was very much a group. Parent sort of endeavor.
But i do draw from from the people who you felt. To come here. Some friendships. So i guess that's the way out.
But that's just i think that's to do with my personality too. I don't know i wouldn't like i didn't like school.
Large groups very much. Anyway. In first place. So it seems odd to have come to a commune. But here in st louis. And.
I think it can be.
Yes i've seen good people who've had good ideas and have been arrested and criticised for them and who've left
and i've seen good strong people who've managed to put their point of view and have stayed.
I think because we were such a low. Generation. Everybody had their opinions and some of them were very good. But that.
That cause people conflict i think that's that sort of thing
and also also seen incredible wisdom in people in that many thing to deal with other people
and to to draw on experiences to to know themselves more and to mature. I've seen both. Really.
I've seen people who are deluded and still are. And i've seen people who've. Who have realized.
Well what did comes down to any in which is that they go to consciousness if you like the fact that god created the
planet and that they had it. They had to care for it and to care for other people i've seen people reach that stage.
And i've seen people. Miss it completely. Both. That's right. Yeah bitch.
You know but it probably did me good i certainly was challenged
and we had thousands of people it seemed like coming through here before the house was built.
The early days were pretty hectic i had little children.
All the things that other people dealt with no water and things like that first that kind of stuff.
But i had it easier than some because i did guard crossed of the boat. Across the border saw that i would co-parent it.
By my mother. And david had work to do sometimes up there so we were coming back and forth.
Some people had it harder than that. You know. That's true. But on the other hand i think some people will hopefully.
I feel that i drew drew support from the group in that. Hard times more. When you reckon that's right. Gone.
Yeah when you get both. That's right. Yeah. And it's tricky it's painful when you get somebody criticising.
I mean i married david and came here and i didn't agree with that rule that they should be no dogs.
I can understand people's logic behind it because there are lots of paddy melons and stuff like that.
But i never would have come to a community where there weren't dogs. So when i tried to bring dogs in and.
Just followed my feelings on that. Because i really think that that. People and animals.
Should be close i think that's why christ was born in a stable. Shot at the animals and people are meant to be close.
And we had the sort of dogs that didn't chase paddy melons but i got into a lot of conflict there and that was hurtful.
But it is i suppose that happens in any walk of life and to a degree. You know.
All the people who want more overt about it here. I don't know if they saw me going oh yeah we say no that's right.
And this is that's what david says my husband. This is the the biggest.
Land cooperative of people have come together and that's one of these donnish really good things about it that.
You said once the fact that people with a tiny bit of capital.
And we were lucky because from david's father we had more capital and other people to set up fruit trees
and to help build a house. But for people with small amount of capital i can get access to land.
And the land has always been locked in a study from. Earliest times. And so that's that's. That was very important.
That was revolutionary and that's something that should be observed.
On the other hand that had it probably its problems too because we. Where we are here were insulated by a creek.
And it. And the forest at the back.
But some people who might have had such a strong personality might have got pushed more into a corner.
In earlier times and not been allowed to have so much land as somebody else who was.
Because it wasn't all set up with rules and regulations.
I think since going on carpeted you might have more fear by trying to make it.
Spelled out at the beginning who could be where and what i had. When. Yeah. Because i haven't seen it. Is that right.
That's what you're talking about there is an icky isn't it. And that. That's the spirit. That's in heaven.
I mean if everybody who had come here. Had had that heavenly vision and had managed to hang on to it.
And you wouldn't have ever had any problem. And that a lot of them did.
But also it was very quickly earth with the with a lot of. Disputes which i guess what.
Had to happen in the physical reality
but that that heavenly vision i don't have any doubt that people had it's really strange but i follow. I follow.
Astrology and and. Our generation was a leo generation that's why i was such an argumentative talkers. But i also had.
They lead i was in pisces which is that.
Which is the sign of the person who is at they all a stage of life and has a heavenly vision.
As well as an earthly vision that's while people sit and dream. They're in heaven. Away.
And so we got our heavenly vision at that age. Some people get it at a different age and.
Everybody has their chance i think to to envision something of that. That christ like thing on the earth.
And i think people did have that but of course. You know. The earth is not perfect.
So some of the things that were done were perfect
and some of them weren't that's a patty it's just that he keeps coming around to the same point to some point. Right.
Good. So yeah right. You know. Oh yes. I think that's probably too i mean true we had we had a fine education and.
I know. We had a lot of skills. From that but i know that. We had more than a lot of other generation's experience.
Of classrooms. To a very light. Age. Especially the ones who went on to to show institutions.
And i know that the early days
and nimbin were partly at a childhood that was played out i mean there was a lot of fun people.
People didn't have no clothes and i didn't walk all over the place. And dance and sing i mean there was that.
Crazy sort of summer of. Of just an innocence in a way. I mean that. That brought its problems too but.
But in a way that. That was a childhood that some people had never had that. I dropped out to to enjoy.
And as a was happens that. There are people with i don't go through a certain stage you've got to do it later.
And a lot of people had a freedom and.
That was that was very beautiful it was it was a celebration there were some very good things that the people enjoyed
in terms of. Just just being free for a lot of innocence well.
People are not longer young i guess and it's not appropriate. I don't think. To try and call that back. That back.
That was a special time i mean there are echoes of it all around but i think that that was a time that was given.
And then you're supposed to get the messages from your time and. Realize the things that you dreamt of.
So i don't think that that's appropriate now. But it was appropriate then.
It was a very special freedom and they were very special friendships. And. And of course.
Many previous generations have been to tightly control and. Six your morality comes into that.